distantly said that I'll make a decision
on the facts and this morning that's
what I did it's been a difficult time
for the team and of course for the
individuals concerned what we know is
that the producer
Ashington Minh was indeed attacked by
Jeremy Clarkson and he was also
subjected to sustained verbal abuse
using words that no one should have to
endure we all know that Jeremy is a huge
talent and has made an extraordinary
contribution to the BBC I've always been
a great fan of his work on top gear and
I also believe that his voice and voices
like his have a place an important place
on the BBC but not at any price physical
violence accompanied by prolonged verbal
abuse has crossed the line and that's
why with regret I decided this morning
that we will not very new renewing
Jeremy's contract
people love Top Gear and I love Top Gear
our priority now is to look to the
future and how we bring it back in good
shape in 2016 whilst recognising it will
be different I also want to make sure
that ash the producer who's at the
center of all this is well looked after
but I just want to end by saying a big
thank you to Jeremy who for nearly 25
years has produced extraordinary work on
Top Gear I wish him all the very best
for the future